we are just days into the open
qualifiers for the first CS2 major and
is already hitting the fan teams
cheating constant delays and a whole
slew of other technical difficulties
that aren't being solved by the team of
apparently useless tournament organizers
this was supposed to be the start of
something new the next era in
Counterstrike but things couldn't be
worse right
[Music]
now if I could describe CS 2 in 2023 in
one word it would probably be
controversial the announcement
practically broke the internet but the
very limited beta left many lifelong
fans feeling shafted and once the game
did come out things got even more
complicated unpolished mechanics
cheaters everywhere and a striking lack
of content but now it's 2024 and a new
beginning a full year of Counterstrike
being kicked off by the first ever major
you see despite Counter-Strike 2's Rocky
Road the tournament thus far have been
pretty solid sure a few hiccups here and
there but what tournament doesn't the
only real caveat is that last year we
were still very much in a transitional
period players were still adjusting and
teams were going to make changes now
there's no excuses it's a fresh start
and everyone gets a chance to find glory
in this new era I was actually pretty
hyped at the idea of it but
unfortunately that was all quickly
soured since the start to this RMR
hasn't been exactly smooth in March the
Copenhagen major will be held by pgl but
the current open qualifiers for it are
being run by Swedish to Challenger mode
now as we all know pgl can be a bit Hit
or Miss especially when it comes to
their Tech issues hello an and welcome
to the championship Sage Challenger mode
on the other hand was used as recently
as the Paris major and from what I could
glean their qualifiers have gone about
as well as any other to's but being the
first ever CS2 major there was a lot of
hype and a lot of pressure going into
this one and well it seems they kind
ofed it up so let's just start with the
logistical issues right out of the gate
we were getting tweets from Pros
complaining about things just not
working the way they were supposed to
you had 3-hour delays due to high server
load teams unable to join matches
causing them to just straight up lose
without even playing and a buggy
anti-che system causing ridiculously
high ping or straight up disconnecting
players forcing teams to play four
versus five now if you're wondering why
this is even happening especially at a
major and why teams aren't being given
more pauses or even replays your guess
is as good as mine to be fair tournament
rules can be pretty rigid so if a team
runs out of pauses because a player
can't connect or you failed a ready
check the game will just move on and
sure the idea of having a bit more
understanding during situations like
these would be nice but given the
hundreds of matches they need to get
through they might just not have the
time but it sure as hell doesn't help
when when the to's lack the manpower to
even attempt to resolve these issues but
more on that later because the show
did not stop here there have been
several instances of players attempting
to inform the TOs of alleged cheaters
who made it into the open
[Music]
qualifiers no
no now this actually happens quite often
in open qualifiers but the sheer amount
of whistleblowing was definitely
concerning and to make things even more
complicated for the to's during one of
OG's matches the coach of the opposing
team was accused of cheating allegedly
coach rofire was in a Discord call with
his team watching a zero delay live
stream of the match and giving his
players information and for some bizarre
reason rofire streamed himself doing
this and as a result his team was
disqualified shortly after beating OG
yes it was resolved and honestly there's
not that much you can do to stop people
from doing blatantly stupid like
this but it just adds to the ongoing
dumpster fire that is this cursed RMR
and maybe these issues would have been
easier to swallow if the admins were
more helpful especially in these massive
open qualifiers it's a big deal that
admins help players with any and all
problems they have but according to
multiple Pros the admins weren't doing
their jobs either taking too long to
respond providing unhelpful information
or not replying altogether some have
suggested sugested that this is due to a
lack of admins to go around but many
aren't accepting this excuse this late
into the game and all that frustration
has seemingly seeped into the Discord
channel for the RMR with users now
spamming porn all in all players and
fans alike aren't happy claiming this is
one of the worst qualifiers in
Counter-Strike history this includes top
Pros who have already spoken out about
their dissatisfaction like Nico dpri and
simple who I must add isn't even there
like I said at the top this was supposed
to be the the official start of the new
Counterstrike era but thanks to pgl's
choice and tournament organizer it's
just another show and awful PR
incident for the game but what's even
scarier is that this might not be
Challenger Mode's fault at all a lack of
Manpower and cheaters sneaking into the
RMR is one thing but what if all the
other issues is a result of the game
itself CS2 has faced hurdle after hurdle
but just because it's a new year doesn't
mean all those problems were magically
solved we won't know unless pgl or
Challenger mode release a statement but
it's possible that they did everything
they could and CS2 just isn't ready for
a tournament of this size so where do we
go from here well pgl could change the
to if it truly is their fault but the
best option right now face it is
probably going to be very expensive and
might not even be possible since they're
technically a competitor now you might
be thinking isn't it worth it in the
name of competitive Integrity to which I
agree but what if they do change in the
problems continue because Counter-Strike
2 just isn't up to the task maybe just
maybe CS 2's first major isn't going to
be as magical as we all hoped it would
be smya put out this tweet that was
probably one of the worst things I've
ever read but since I had to read it now
all of you guys are subjected to it he
said quote I think I'd rather put a
toothpick under my toenail and boot the
wall then deal with this Open qualifier
experience again so thanks for that
smooya really didn't want to think about
that torture tactic